and now we turn to another YouTube star
and that is pbd Patrick that David is
founder and CEO of value attainment and
host of the pbd podcast and he joins us
to talk the latest on Trump DeSantis
Tucker and much much more Pat welcome
back to the show how are you
I'm great would you be caught dead in
the little Nas cat outfit did you see
the little it's like the it's squeezing
him up the bottom and it's squeezing him
down in the front and there's really I
mean gay is one thing not one interview
being a man left is another what's Wild
is how how they're using him to Market
him you know he gets all the eyeballs
and God forbid somebody else stands out
there and says hey boys be a man hey
boys stand up for yourself hey go out
there and defend yourself hey be
protective of women take care of the
folks around you you know go out there
and make some money go out there and do
something for yourself if we give a
message that is very much of a pro-man
message God forbid you say something
like that but little Naz X hey put him
all over the place you know what he's
wearing oh this is this guy's a
superstar he's a hero and unfortunately
it's confused in a lot of different
people but for me to wear something like
that I don't even think I would wear
something like that privately for my
wife no no and nor would she want you to
I think I speak
it's I've seen Borat it's not a good
look
with my kids uh because I follow him on
insta videos of Jocko willink you know
who's like the Navy SEAL to end all Navy
Seals oh yeah and this morning we
watched a video uh it was it was uh
Jocko discussing with Leif Babin who
married my friend Jenna Lee from Fox
Business
um uh buds training and how the Seal
team is like so much about so much more
than buds training yes it's difficult
but it's like you carried some logs and
water the way they described it like it
doesn't compare at all to combat and War
and like that is who I want especially
my boys listening to and looking at
somebody like a you know some a man of
service a man of Honor a man who in some
of his other messages says whatever it
is it's your fault you take
responsibility not somebody else you
that's this whole thing extreme
accountability
um not this not these ridiculous people
Pat I can't
well listen this is why uh Jaco is
another Super necessary voice and what
is happening is if you ask me what the
biggest leak is the challenge what
happened with parents and kids is
whoever you and I edify as the hero the
kids want to be whatever we edify the
kids want to be so if you edify a man
like Jocko and your son is watching and
saying hey son watch this man Jocko
that's what you call a man your son's
gonna be like my mom is edifying Jocko I
want to be like Jocko when I grow up I
want to be like broken when I grow up I
want to be like this man when I grow up
right these guys are showing there's a
guy named Petro's good friend is an
entrepreneur he's doing things where
father and sons are coming learning
about how to become men there's a
bonding thing that's going on with the
father and son they're doing push-ups
they're training they're helping each
other out they're going out there doing
all these exercises there's a lot of
good opportunities out there I read a
recently we did a video on why the
number one earners immigrants in America
are Indian Americans not native
Americans indian like from India
Americans they make more money on
average in America than any other
ethnicity in America including whites
they make on average 120 000 per year
number two just so you know is that
ninety five thousand dollars and whites
were at sixty five thousand dollars so
then you said this is kind of
interesting let's take a look at this
because they're only one percent of the
U.S population but eight percent of all
the startups you know when they're going
to technology and all this stuff there's
all these success stories of how they
invest their kids into stem all these
things that they're doing so then I went
on this one website to see what's so
special about Indian parenting that's
different than others so you go to this
website
it's called India parenting they have
these 10 points there and one of the
points was how they edify whatever
Behavior they want so you over edify you
edify and say see what Johnny did great
job Johnny see what that guy's doing
great job that's what you call it either
that's what you call this that's what
you call that versus American parents
are like where it's okay if they feel
that way well it's okay if you feel this
way well it's okay if you feel that way
no that's a leader that's a man that's
this they're edifying them right but one
of the points also out of the 10 of
Megan which was kind of interesting is
they also judge they're not afraid to
judge bad behavior and said they're very
judgmental of bad behavior interesting
concept typically when we hear the word
judge we don't think about it in a
positive way say no Indian parents they
edify great behavior and they judge bad
behavior unfortunately the current
Society in America today we are a little
bit too accepting of every single
behavior and these kids are grown up
saying if Mom's not judging that if
Mom's not edifying that I guess I'm just
going to choose to be the you know
little knowledge X I'm going to look up
to this guy you know Sam Smith I'm going
to go look up this guy so I think we
have a hero making machine problem in
America and parents need to paint a
better picture of what a hero is for
their kids so well said I agree with
every word you said it's it's I think in
part I'm not saying because I know I
have a dear friend who's a conservative
he's a lawyer and he has a a daughter
who's struggling with the gender
identity stuff so I'm not saying it
never happens to conservatives but I do
think that there's a reason why this
whole trans explosion is happening in
these more leftist cities more than
anywhere else and why you have people
like the Disney executive who's like my
one child is polyamorous and my other
child is trans and my other child is a
furry like whatever really because
there's it's no accident that that's
happening because like that that's not
going to happen in my family and I'll
tell you there's another woman who I
knew in New York
um she's black her husband's black and
she said that she was very concerned
about this trans ideology at our school
where they were asking our boys whether
they were concerned whether they were
sure they were boys everywhere and she
said at home she and her husband were
counter programming like can you imagine
Grandpa showing up in a dress like they
were doing some mild mocking of it so
that their boys understood this is
absurd and not an available option for
you
yeah you know as crazy as it is uh uh
one of the fears Megan you know you've
made a lot of money in your life you're
very successful you're at the top of the
game uh uh you're the best at what you
do okay so that's Megan Kelly you're not
in the top one person you're more like
one percent of one percent okay so
you've been fortunate I've been
fortunate we've done good for ourselves
financially so we can kind of use our
resources to you know push our weight a
little bit right like if you're going
like if I'm interviewing for schools
that I was putting my kids into I went
to seven different private schools here
in South Florida one of my first
question was so hey Mary you know thank
you so much for taking the time for the
appointment uh with us and our three
kids we're looking forward to coming to
Florida how does this school feel about
capitalism excuse me yeah how do you
feel about what do you think about these
rich people these entrepreneurs these
capitalists these business owners who
had what is the school's position on
capitalism
well we we teach the benefits of of
capitalism and the pros and cons of it
but we also teach the pros and cons of
socialism and we teach pros and cons of
Communism and we allow the kids to
decide yeah my kids are not going to go
to your school I mean yeah how much more
history do you need to not have to teach
the pros of Communism how many millions
of people have been killed so these are
the questions that parents with
resources can ask but Megan I want you
to think about this
think if you and I are making seventy
four thousand dollars a year okay
household income we have is 120 let's
say 130 okay 30 of that goes to taxes so
if you're making one Thirty thirty
percent goes to taxes you're left with
ninety seven thousand dollars let's just
say ninety five thousand dollars
you're living in a three bedroom house
maybe a four bedroom house uh 30 minutes
outside of the city because that's what
we can afford and our kids can only go
to a public school and now you go and
impose yourself with these things so
parents are now coming home and the kids
asking questions about lgbtq then the
parent tries to explain this to the kid
then the kid goes to school and says
well my mommy told me then the Teacher
Calls the parent and says hey you can't
tell that to your kids now the parent is
afraid doesn't know what to do because
they could get kicked out now they're
being boxed in a place that you are a
extremist and all this stuff then the
teachers can Target do you see how this
thing creates the kind of fear and
parents that they're immobilized so that
causes a lot of parents to say well look
babe don't say that to them because he's
going to say that and go hey son you
can't go tell that to your teacher it's
Cree I remember living in Iran with my
parents going to a school and worried
about the Hezbollah pulling us over and
if they ask you are you a Christian you
got to say ask my mommy and my daddy
some parents right now in low and middle
income families are right now going
through this and making I got to tell
you that's a scary place to be you and I
may not know about it today you and I
may not know the fears of that but tens
of millions of people are going through
that today so what do they do what's the
solution is it best to just kind of sit
on the sidelines and let other people
steal your kids for 20 years and I don't
mean physically I mean emotionally and
philosophically and now your kid doesn't
like you because your teachers and the
school system pinned you against your
kids and they come home and they say all
you care about is this what do you do
this is where bitching and complaining
is not enough this is where sitting on
the sidelines and just talking to other
parents and yeah you know Johnny's mom
also feels this way this is when we got
to get involved there's never ever Megan
been a better time or more important of
a time of a side gig do real estate on
the side
do something on the side to create an
additional two three four five thousand
dollars a month to either put your kids
in a private school or to homeschool or
on top of that if you can't do any of
that stuff based on where you live get
involved right now School boards uh the
voting percentage is not that high it
only it's like five percent voting five
to ten percent voting if you go vote or
turnout is not high and parents who run
typically they have a very high chance
of winning so if you're sitting there
saying well I'm not happy about what's
going on run for school board you would
be surprised how many other parents feel
like you and you become the Courageous
one and other people in public school
say I kind of like what Mary has to say
let's get behind her right you have to
find a way of creating that power to
vote with your feet or speak up at
school and be listened to you know it
it's getting easier I mean I will say
it's easier when I was in the city at
the school I just referenced where
they're asking our boys if they're girls
every week
um we form this sort of underground
network of parents and that's where I
met the friend I was telling you and and
as I mentioned that she and her husband
are black they were they didn't did not
appreciate the messages going to their
brilliant son that he was somehow less
than because of the color of his skin
which was the implicit message of
America's original sin and there's
really no way around it and you somehow
are divided from your white and your
Indian your brown skinned classmates and
you Hispanics too you're in the same
boat she and the other parents of color
were as mad as we were
um where they were saying you know as
I've told you the world before about the
white kids in every classroom where
white children learn there's a future
killer cop and teaching that there are a
hundred genders and refusing to refer to
the boys as boys now or as your sons as
Sons now it's just your student this hit
the news just this week that in Vermont
there's this school it's like uh I'll
pull up the name like Founders I can't
remember like friends I've figured out
um where they're they're getting rid of
same thing they're they're only
referring to boys as um
people who make sperm and girls as
people who make eggs
in school now and these parents in
Vermont this is not you know this is
Vermont which is a blue state but come
on it's still America
[Music]